c'est un nouveau cri de détresse poussé
par les habitants face à l'aggravation
de la situation dans leur pays ce mardi
soir ils étaient des centaines à
manifester dans plusieurs villes du
liban dont la capitale beyrouth déjà
touché par une grave crise économique
le pays du cèdre a vu sa monnaie
nationale atteindre son plus bas
historique sur le marché noir
frôlant les 10 milliards pour un dollar
une dégringolade qui a provoqué la
colère de la rue
comment les gens avec des familles
doivent acheter du lait et des couches
pour leurs enfants
aujourd'hui si vous allez au supermarché
qui vous dépenser entre 200 et 1000 et
300 mille livres libanaises vous
n'achetez que quelques petites choses
notre situation se détériore chaque jour
le pouvoir d'achat est si bas vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer il n'y a pas
d'essence au liban pour faire un plan il
n'y a pas d'électricité pour chauffer
nos maisons notre peuple est au chômage
le prix du pain est exorbitant et nous
ne pouvons plus rester à la maison
le liban est engluée dans la pire crise
économique de son histoire aggravée par
une impasse politique et la pandémie de
kovy de 10,9
face à cette situation dramatique le
président michel aoun a appelé les
libanais du monde entier à soutenir leur
pays la diaspora peut aider le liban en
y font dans des institutions et en
créant des opportunités d'emploi pour sa
jeunesse
cela permettrait de réduire l' envie
qu'on les jeunes d'émigrer en raison de
la situation actuelle
une nouvelle chute qui intervient au
moment où la banque centrale du liban a
commencé à passer aux cris d' la
situation financière des établissements
bancaires du pays
ces derniers avaient jusqu'à dimanche
dernier pour augmenter leur capital de
20%
une des mesures réclamées par la banque
centrale pour doper leur solvabilité et
leur niveau de liquidité
la dépréciation de la livre libanaise a
déjà entraîné en 2020 une hausse
drastique des prix un habitant sur deux
vit désormais sous le seuil de pauvreté